foreign
for CBS deals this morning we have
products that just might help you relax
unwind and perhaps feel just a bit
pampered and all at exclusive low prices
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle experts Christian
joins us with more good morning so nice
to see you Rochelle and so happy to be
here with Israel this morning listen
we've got some great products I want you
to start with solowave.com run and try
this because this sold out last time so
pick up that wand right there okay so
the solo wave wand is red light
technology and you know you go to the
spots you get that red light technology
so what does red light technology do put
it onto your skin right now it will
activate with the touch of your skin
really does is actually yeah promotes
collagen it gets rid of acne it also
wrinkles put them on your crow's feet
I've actually got redness right over
here it works it works it works awesome
um and Rachel Zoe who's a style expert
actually said that this is the best
beauty Budget Buy for 2021 put it on her
Zoe report we're looking at 100 less
than 100 and 33 percent off wow that is
a savings what about this I love
luxurious candle four-wick candle and
we're talking about Aroma 360. I lit
this up in my house yesterday fantastic
yes that's why they call it Aroma 360.
essential oils uh we're talking about
Bergamot we're talking about Amber you
light it up it's four Wicks and you know
people come in and look at your house
you got one two three four wigs they
look super Luxe so this is less than 100
and we're talking about a savings of 61
I love it I've always asked the question
why do we need different glasses you
need it because to have that wine
connoisseur experience and believe it or
not we're looking at the hotel
collection and this is all about five
star luxurious collection it's about
five star luxury in your house you've
got white wine glasses red wine glasses
and champagne glasses that's red wine
white wine Vin salmon you're better than
me you're better than me I got a dry
January going on let me give you the
deal right now we're talking about
discount of 26 off and we're talking
about under 40 44 about 44.50 right
there okay what we got here calm and
cozy yes it's common cozy and we all
need to be kamikozy on these cold days
kamikozy and it's a massage heating wrap
feel how Luxe it is so basically you
could attach this strap onto your chair
this thing is portable you kind of put
yourself into it it's like a blanket but
it also massages yourself it's got a
setting yeah it's perfect we're talking
about a discount of 40 off and it's less
than fifty four dollars so look at that
you attach yourself to the chair it's
like you're working from home but you're
getting a massage tell me you don't love
it and this is great for the athlete in
your life as well it comes in different
colors take a look at this 40 off go to
cbsdeals.com you will love it quick
question and that's for the bottom half
is there a part yes the top half no it
comes up all the way up here okay but
you know you want to be all the way up
so here we have really entrenched
ourselves in the bathroom okay I love
this product because it's called beloved
bath lavender scent it came from two
moms who have autistic sons and they
wanted to create employment for kids
with autism so everything here is made
with somebody who has autism when it
comes to the beautiful heart soap we've
got the lavender body butter and this
beautiful candle and so you're looking
at some of the video of some of the
people that are employed through this
beautiful beloved bath now Pam and Pat
created this and so you're putting your
money where it counts we're talking
about a 32 percent discount and we're
talking an exclusive deal for 38.50 go
to cbsdeals.com I mean serious this is
gorgeous stuff so good so kind of thank
you I love you good to see you of course
we partner with all of these companies
to get these deals to buy anything you
saw today scan that QR code on your
screen or head over to CBS deals dot com